we're going to look now that Dostoevsky
notes from the underground yeah this is
a classic piece of existential
literature it's kind of a hybrid between
a confession of those philosophical
treatise and a short story written from
the first person perspective been very
intellectual the development of later
existentialist walk can cite that quite
often and it's even had some importance
outside existentialism per se
particularly because of some of the
striking images like the Crystal Palace
worked out in this piece so why is it an
important existentialist text that's
worth reflecting on before we dig into
is this a representation of the
existentialist stance towards the self
or its world towards reality towards
emotions towards rationality towards
culture and society those relations
between people yes or no I don't think
that you could actually say that there's
one single existentialist stance point
that various writers had made within the
existentialist movement talking about
the existentialist movement it doesn't
seem possible to pin everything down and
very neatly and to say here is the one
example already at the beginning and we
have Kierkegaard Dostoevsky Anita
as these seminal figures and they're
quite different from each other is it
then the typical existentialist dance it
is a typical existential stance we're
going to see not necessarily the one
single element but age difficulties that
part of why it's got the importance of
it does like I said some of the other
important stems from its stock of images
like the Crystal Palace will get there
one of the things that I think we have
to ask at the beginning that's going to
run through this entirely in which the
character himself is in some way is
trying to work out yes who is this
underground man who is this character
who is this is Mara who is this person
and one thing that I would caution to
you about right from the start is
identifying the underground man with
Dostoevsky himself sometimes this this
takes place it's important to see that
the character is not necessarily the
walk characters not necessarily the
mouthpiece
a similar mistake gets made by people
who only read America moves the stranger
and they assume that the stance the
attitudes the sets events the ideas the
main character and the happies Express
who those three halves gets a little bit
harder to pin down part of the genius
seems to have that actually spitting out
care
who represents coherent perspectives
butter but are not necessarily putting
them into play major ethical moral
existential dilemmas so we don't know we
don't want to I think if I Dostoevsky
very clearly with this
so what's he doing he is exploring
itself and human nature through a
particular person kind of tired
not necessarily humanity as such he's
not saying this one guy is the image
involve human beings or even the most
authentic human being he freaks things
and this is where we asked is the
character isn't Dostoevsky himself isn't
this just a literary the fiction this is
just like him playing around with things
and this thing else key tells us a few
things
not much but just a very few things
there is a footnote where Dostoevsky as
an author writes it goes without saying
that both these notes and their life
there are fictitious nevertheless people
like the author of these notes may and
indeed must exist in our society if we
think of the circumstances under which
that society has been formed it's been
my wish to show the public a character
of the recent past more clearly than is
usually shown he belongs to the
generation that is now rounding out its
days in the excerpt of mouthfuls man
introduces himself and presents his
views trying to explain why is a period
or did that help it appear in our midst
the next exert consists of this man's
action notes relating to certain events
like so he's adopting this this literary
fiction
literary device of saying I found he's
not saying that found these notes and
I'm replicating them but something like
this for ought to be the case in a way
reminds me a little bit of vicinities if
you if you've read the cinema is the
great greek historian here accounts a
lot of speeches one of the things that
he says about his is you might say
process of quotation is I'm not actually
giving you these speeches for bata
exactly as they were said I'm giving you
sometimes what the characters ought to
have said given the kind of person who
they were so Creon may not have actually
said the things that he that Thucydides
says that he reports that he said but he
sent something like it and he said
something along those lines because
Priya was the kind of guy to do that at
the very end
Dostoevsky also tells us this is kind of
interesting he says actually the notes
of this lover of paradoxes do not end
here he couldn't resist him went on
writing but we are the opinion that one
might just as well stop here so
Dostoevsky he's doing something very
interesting here he's saying well the
writer of these notes and now now he's
not saying oh yeah this is the kind of
thing that
because you know would have come on the
scene now he's actually presenting it as
if I do have these notes in front of me
and I'm just copying them for you who
reader
he says they keep going on and on and on
they should have stopped here because
though the person says that's enough
I've had enough of writing these notes
from the underground that's the last
thing from the underground means the
notes themselves does genre if we had to
pick a genre that it fits closest to is
a confession and the the writer actually
brings this up in a couple of times he
says I'm trying to put matters down I'm
trying to make sense of them I'm trying
to rap he doesn't say wrap my head
around them but that's the sort of way
to talk about it now he talks about
these as being admissions he says
I've taken a fancy into my head and I
want to realize that any cost I've got
and I'm going to follow that through
what I mean is there are things in every
man's past and he won't admit except his
most intimate friends there are other
things that he won't admit even to his
friends but only to himself and only in
strictest confidence but there are
things to a man who won't dare to admit
even to himself and every decent man has
quite an accumulation of such things in
fact the more decent he is the greater
the accumulation he's about to have I
have only recently dared to explore some
of my past adventures which until then I
had avoided with the part with peculiar
anxiety but now that I have made myself
remember then even dared to write them
down I want to make a test to see
whether it is possible to become to be
completely Frank and unafraid of the
whole truth I would like to know yours i
jus marked the effect that sincere
autobiographies are almost as possible
as bound to lie about himself I'm sure
mine is relative but I was passing
judgment on a man confessing publicly
now in my case I'm writing this just for
myself for even if I do address myself
to imaginary readers I do it only
because it makes it easier for me to
write it's a matter of for nothing else
for as I said before I'll never have any
readers so there's a lot of paradoxes
involved here aren't there and we don't
have to explore those in great depth
this is worth pointing about is
Dostoevsky expecting the reader for this
is the guy who's actually talking and
expecting a reader he's addressing
readers but now it looks as if he's
doing that just so he can kind of pull
the truth out of himself and it's not
one pair
the other one is it consistent a word he
says unafraid unafraid of the whole
truth so what's one of the most common
aspects that you see running through
this this story the fear anxiety fear of
all sorts of events along with that
cowardice of courage so this guy by
laying out a paper his moments of
cowardice is being unafraid is that yet
another way of trying sort of consoled
himself and make him feel like he's not
a coward really as a coward or is there
a greater sense of courage here that
trumps other courage the kind of courage
that we tend to respect and look at as
being instances of the type
wouldn't that be very much along the
lines that you could expect that a
bitter impotent intellectual who's
disdainful of people of action and
spontaneity might say as a response to
try to elevate their own kind of courage
it's sort of like the well I'm less is a
hypocrite because I confess that I'm a
hypocrite and there's you know on the
one hand they're sort of bringing the
truth to that and on the other hand sort
of atonement in sincerity so I got there
to another parasites let's talk now
about the talk about how dosti as we put
this together since we're talking about
position there's two parts this if we
take out the narrative framing that dose
today on skating songs but again these
little notes at the beginning in that
the first part is the mouse ball and
that is it starts out assuming to be
kind of rambling and recounting who he
is and then it starts to get more and
more and more philosophical and
eventually rages of keep essentially
being something like a philosophical
treatise still addressed to a reader so
there's a dialectical dialogical element
to there's that and then this the entire
second half is a story about how this
guy got involved in these as he calls
them adventures during the course of
which he borrow some money
meets up with some old school
acquaintances goes to a dinner with them
neglects to pay as his servants for the
time being makes it the acid themselves
at dinner for reasons and we can talk
about later goes off to a brothel meets
a prostitute has a long conversation
with her gives her his address leaves
has a few days past and that she comes
to his place and they have another
reaction which turns out largest not
quite badly those are the sort of things
that he's talking about
that's the put
things that a person wanting to admit to
his friends or to himself every decent
man is quite an accumulation of such
things and these are his past adventures
which he had avoided with the part with
peculiar anxiety he doesn't want to
think about these things what it was
says about herself and the pointlessness
or failure so all that said let's go
back that's who who is this guy what
does he tell us about it was there is
some viagra this is all a lot of them
I'm not sure exactly how much we ought
to trust it all be able to go on this is
what he gives us so we can see whether
biography the facts about him and then
we can ask about his character what do
we know he's an orphan
we know that he talks about growing up
without parents he went to school there
he met a lot of people he seems to excel
in what we might call abstract or
scholastic kind of studies and was
singled out then he entered government
service he actually entered it in order
to make a living and then transferred
from one department to another he says
so he could get away from his former
schoolmates so he's a kinda he's a guy
who goes from a terrific characters a
kind of guy who leaves things behind
might say unfinished he works as a
government employer for a while as a
clerk and then after he receives a small
inheritance he quits and he moves to an
apartment in the city of Petersburg
where it was located before he really
can't afford it that well he has to
scrape by he could live
the place is cheaper but he chooses to
live in Petersburg and not so great area
of town and essentially the business on
this disinheritance so he doesn't really
do much of anything at that he talks
with his wife his head Anton Anton he
has only acquaintances and he is a
pretty isolated man
it's it's it's not really correct to say
that that's his only acquaintance
because if we look at the story he runs
across other people who he knows
remembers from school he also has a
servant who he doesn't he doesn't get
along with people at all quite frankly a
servant doesn't appear to be a
particularly good type either but it
would be hard to work for a guy like
this so I can I can just imagine you
know what the interactions would be like
he's pretty eyes when he's the thinker
he's an intellectual he's not extremely
practical but he is able to get quite a
few things done borrow money from people
for one thing he manages to keep things
more or less straight so he's not just a
dreamer his head in the clouds but like
he says his action is infected with
ideas and one of the things that I think
is really talking about it goes to
character he he is an intellectual he
can't stop thinking he thinks too much
in the wrong ways he he engages in
reflection that doesn't generate an
awful lot of understanding it's as if no
matter what you say to the guy he's
always got one more
to say that's being suggested to him
it's popping into his head but there's
an insecurity there about his capacity
to think not only you know sense of
futility like what the hell is all this
for you know other people seem to be
succeeding quite better than me and
being an intellectual was masking that
makes it particularly happy compared to
being a person of action but he actually
seems to be very concerned that other
people think of him as an intellectual
so here's a great he's going into the
hospital so he says let my face be
played as long as it's dignified
expressive and above all incredibly
intelligent I was painfully aware that
my facial expression could not possibly
convey all these qualities and worse yet
well I'd have settled for anything as
long as it looked intelligent they found
my face positively stupid item two even
accepted a priyad expression if at the
same time everyone had agreed everyone
had agreed I love that line that I had a
terribly him touched his face so this is
a guy he is an intellectual he is a
thinker he can't escape that he does hit
him but he wants other people people
that he seems not to care at all about
he wants other people to think of him
not only as intelligent but as terribly
intelligent and as they have even being
written on his face so there is a
fundamental insecurity there something
that can't possibly be says right so he
says that and again this goes to his
character he says he is really painfully
sensitive and complex as a man of this
should what does he mean by this he
means an age which is becoming
enlightened which people are no longer
relating to each other just in terms of
feudal relations or economic relations
or wartime through some pretty tough
times you know just half a century
before but they're relating to each
other in in other ways the world of the
wine does penetrate of the other world
so to speak he lacks a stable sense of
who or what he is he lacks persistence
or perseverance or consistency he talks
about this in terms of not being able to
stick to things and yet not even being
lazy in the sense of being able to say
that guy is a lazy guy and being able to
say now I know what he is who he is
so this is this is a real problem
he's never able to even follow through
on revenge and he gets some examples of
that so he's also capable of decent
human interactions and he doesn't do
that he does do them sometimes but he
can't be relied upon to continue doing
them he can't be relied upon to
consistently theyhave like a decent
human being
so every once in a while it'll just say
something cruel like you know for
instance when he's at the retirement
dinner for his friend well that his
friend that his acquaintance stream from
school and she throws in there a bar you
know this person of course this person
who's retired is talking about how what
a great guy he is who's doing was
name-dropping that's what the
underground man says yeah how come so
and so they would come to your party and
it's it's not just committing a faux pas
there's a maliciousness involved but not
a maliciousness like again I'm gonna get
that guy alright here comes my chance
more like oh there's a chance to do
something mean I'll do it so that's what
that's that's a part of his character
Warners typical moves we're going to
talk a little bit more about about this
let's note right now the part of his
character central part of his character
the moods that used to give talking
about the most are on two different ends
one is fear anxiety concern about what
people are going to think and perhaps a
sense of shame the other is resentment
irritation maliciousness these are these
are most of you
his range of feelings he doesn't also
talk about joy he also talks about
desire but the two main stars in the
constellation are I think anger and fear
he makes some remarks of that about
reading somewhat relevant about
dissolution and we're going to look at
that in in just a moment he also talks
about about love and so here we're
focusing on his character and there are
certain passages that are very reviewed
so let's look at why reading is so
important to this guy I mean you can
understand for an intellectual reading
would be who he is but there are
different ways of reading the spiritual
reading that a monk does each day
there's something very different than
the kind of reading that he's doing the
reading that somebody does to study to
pass the bar exam after going through
loss was very different
he's talking so he says the poem I
mostly read I had to drown out the clam
in the reading was the only available
way so there's a clamor inside of him
there's a there's a disquiet a
restlessness inside of him and reading
is a way to take care of that and I
think we know a lot of people and maybe
some of us are like that ourselves at
times who read to escape so long as we
can fix our minds on somebody else's
story some other issue we are let away
from looking at ourselves and our own
turmoil and trials and failures so says
reading of course was helpful it stirred
delight in tormenting me now and then
whoever I'm terribly tired of it
I became Restless and plunged not into
the real debauchery but it's a murky
sordid petty dissipation my petty
passion stand and burn me because I was
already on edge I suffered hysterical
outbursts of tears and convulsions so
this is a guy who breaks down in her
salon by himself he does actually have a
crime
the prostitute later out of the story
but that doesn't seem to be typically
what happens diamonds are real
debauchery
he doesn't count going to the so the
whorehouse is real debauchery although
he you can tell he doesn't at that time
because he talks about when he goes to
the brothel this being a place with it
that he knows already but into murky
story the penny dissipation aside from
my reading I had nothing to turn to for
there was nothing in my surroundings
that I could look up to or that
attracted me I was sick of everything in
long to contradict and oppose longed to
contradict and oppose that's another key
who these guys and leads to what is the
factor because the fact is he says
things to people to take them along or
to to show them that he's not you know
seeing things the same way as that or
but he has some power over them well
they're not going to make him do things
their way we'll see why that's such a
strong virtually so it says I abandon
myself to dissipation I indulged in
place at night steadily fearfully sort
of Lee the feeling of shame was always
present and in the most unspeakable
moments it was like damnation itself
here that I carry this whole
my heart that's a beautiful expression
of an ugly thing even that I carry this
hole in the floor of my heart I was
terribly afraid to be seen and
recognized and I went to Louis wants so
he did engage in some fights what were
his vices you know probably the typical
things that people do drinking you know
to excess getting it to Harvey minutes
talking you know just for the sake of
talking gossiping lying people
pick ups one-night stands those sorts of
things he actually gives us this funny
incident once passing about a tavern I
want I saw some men fighting with
billiard accused threw a lighted window
one of them was tossed out of the window
int the ejected gentleman so much ahead
to the Tiananmen step to the familiar
who thinking maybe I could pick a fight
to and be thrown out the window how many
times about this this whole thing with
this officer who treats it like an
object but what else is going on so he
is going to talk about reading some more
later reading is an escape for him from
his life in which he is not entirely
inactive he isn't actually out there
pursuing these from any sort of
pleasures what about the law well that's
where we get back to reading reading and
dreaming he says that he resigned
himself sometimes I had an escape that
made everything bearable I took refuge
and the sublime and the beautiful in my
dreams I gave myself over entirely to
dreaming dreaming away for three months
and then Holland in my corner and
believe me in my dreams I had nothing in
common with my dreams were sweeter and
stronger after my petit dissipations at
work
by remorse tears cursing and ecstasy I
experienced moments of actual
intoxication and I swear was happy
without finding it in the least
ridiculous that's a strange thing to say
to him to be happy without finding your
happiness ridiculous this is a man who
is in some respect afraid of having
assistant I had faith hope the three
theological virtues so what are we
talking about here part of this is he's
a guy who you know does he is these
small sins these small faults and then
afterwards in his dreams you know rape
does that into some sort of a narrative
presumably don't like repentance of
conversion and you know we can all
imagine have like you know conversing
with angels and saints in these dreams
and expecting you know God on the right
side finally and I've been searching for
you all those sorts of images right
[Music]
that's just it I had blind faith that by
some miracle some force would push aside
they can find the screen opening up a
wider horizon on which would be a
worthwhile and life work useful and
sublime and above all all cut out and
waiting for me I didn't know what kind
of work it should be but it was
essential that it should be there ready
and waiting for me to perform it now
that's a really interest
to go from these servers religious views
and all that which you know really being
belittled Camilla is the second
personality is being able to say I go
where I have to because you know that's
where God wants me and I'm really not
that important
what is he dreamed about she dreams of
that being she dreams about having
things fall into place about like it
says horizons opening up and they test
being set out for me that is mine and
mine alone my purpose that which would
make me be someone who matters who is
able to step in and do those sorts of
things useful and sublime useful for
other people and yet some wine could be
to fall in love with somebody to to make
their life wonderful it could be to
engage in some sort of magnificent
gestures it could be to say to the
nation through policing the streets or
routing the enemy it could be any
certainly could be a victory in the life
of one lady says I couldn't even
conceive of being second-best that's why
in real life I resigned myself so easily
to being last if he can't hang on the
top then screw it all and you've seen
people like this right the more and more
than we regard this person the less and
less the scene
like just a literary invention on those
two essence part I had to be either a
hero or wallow in the mind that's what
turned out to be my undoing for a while
while bringing the mud I consoled myself
that at other times it was a hero that
made it all right so this is a way of
escape through him again yeah again it
says it's noteworthy I usually thought
of the supply of beautiful during my
dissipation well often just money at the
rock-bottom of objection then these
thoughts came in little flashes as if to
remind me of the existence of the
sublime and the beautiful but they
didn't interfere with my dissipation
just the opposite of the fact they
seemed to spice it up by contrasting
like a good sauce to help to bring out
the taste so I mean like right while he
was doing bad things he's thinking tucks
off these these dreams this sauce
concocted of contradictions and
suffering contained painful
self-analysis and the resulting nagging
ease and torment and pick and see and
even meaning to my dissipation ensure it
was what a good [ __ ] has meant to be
there was more to it though for without
the sauce and hardly have borne the
permit to vulgar uncomplicated
dissipation of a petty government
employee and the soil of feeling that
had left could ne vais have drawn me
into the street at night otherwise no
then I have the sauce so it's
interesting he's claiming that because
he's got these these moments of dreaming
and thinking of himself as being this
imaginary here are the things are going
to open up for him that's somehow that's
what enables him that doesn't just help
him get it through the day that's what
actually enables him to go out at night
and get drunk and get laid because
otherwise you wouldn't maybe have the
heart for that now we get to another
variant how much love I experienced in
my dreams when I escaped to the sublime
and beautiful
perhaps it was an imaginary law but
maybe was never directed toward
being but it was such an overflowing
love there was no need to direct it that
would have been an unnecessary mushroom
so he feels this this aspect of love and
it's not for anything in particular it's
just a sense of law they had to single
it out anyone things as would have been
a luxury everything always in it safely
and leisurely rapture rapture sliding
into the domain of art that isn't to the
beautiful lives of hero stolen from the
authors and novels of poems and adapted
to the demands of the moment whatever
they might be I for instance triumph
over everyone and there of course drew
another dust acknowledging my
superiority I'm all forgiven I'm a great
poet in court Chamberlain I fall in love
I had Herrick millions and donate them
to human causes and take advantage of
this opportunity to publicly confess my
backslidings in disgrace which of course
is no ordinary disgrace but contains
much those sublime and beautiful that
everyone is weeping and kissing me that
I made hungry and barefoot to preach new
ideas throughout the reactionaries and
Telstra myths so again it's grandiose
ideas about what he's going to do is
interesting you notice that okay I'm
talking about the law and I feel this
love for everybody and it's reaching out
towards everything and that very quickly
it starts to become above itself and
it's less about my expression of love
for these other people it's more about
how they welcome P if I'm such a lovable
person and that's really what this guy
is is lacking
he does not feel in any sense his own
sense of law what love consistent is
well it's very problematic to say the
least
I'm a rated a passage he sees a person
who actually loves and then this
prostitute when he breaks down himself
he goes into this long speech about her
ways he is essentially rejecting her of
every different level and he says at
this point a very strange thing happened
I was so used to imagining and
everything happened in the way it
doesn't books I didn't pay attention to
what was going on what actually happened
was that lies who I had humiliated it
crushed understood much more than I had
thought
but of all that that I had said she had
understood what a sincerely loving woman
would understand first and I myself was
unhappy notice he's able to see her as a
sincerely loving woman because of her
action towards him so it's not as if
he's totally blind to what love
consistent what shape did love take for
him as he is he's giving it to other
people he says I couldn't follow because
for me loving means bullying and
dominating I have never been able to
imagine any other way of loving and have
reached a point where to me love
consists of the voluntary concession
by the object of my love of my right to
bully it even dreaming it my mouth I've
never visualized love is anything but a
struggle
starting with hatred and ending in the
subjection of the love object after
which I was unable to think of anything
so this is this is love desire
it's not even desire to it's nothing
euros like the desire to have sex the
desire more contempt would have to be in
the same presence of the person for him
to long beings to dominate to believe
and he can tell that the things are
going well with him
this actually reminds me of earlier the
passage where he talks about me having a
acquaintance in school he was not liked
by the most of the other kids but he
wasn't liked by another kid until he
will lead him and he told them that it
had to be either him and the southern
kid against everyone else or nothing
that wasn't you know a chance for him to
do something different and what's
interesting particularly interesting
about this he's able to recognize that's
not all there is to love but that's all
there is to love for him the the key
issue that we've been moving towards
here the central point walk around with
all of those terms is that there's a
disconnect for the underground man and
that's for all of us but it's a way that
he handles it to manage there's a
disconnect between how things are at the
only how they want to be how they're
represented
in books in dreams in plans and our
intentions and their hopes our
aspirations and then how they actually
turn out to be a reality and an
integrated person is able not only to be
integrated with it themselves but to
integrate those dreams hopes and all
that with the reality there's two ways
of not being integrated well accounts of
those two fundamental ways one is to
give in to reality and that's the way it
is it's dog-eat-dog screw everyone I'm
just going to be like these people over
here figure out how to get along and all
those hopes dreams that indeed evolves
go out the window was being unrealistic
that's to kill part of yourself and to
kill actually some line in the beautiful
right a very good part of herself that
true maybe has to be you know tempered
to some degree and then we have to get
to know through through books that are
kind of misleading sometimes the other
way is to do with the underground to
take refuge in this reality which ends
up being a threadbare he's not the kind
of idealist who but we use his BS
believes his ideologies you know makes
reality conformed to do that would be a
man of action right he's one who wants
that ID ality to be reality can't make
it so and it's reality as a result in
response now is this the human condition
[Music]
this is the human condition in many
respects
people what you can think about the
underground man is he's not depicting
the human condition as such for all
human beings what he's really showing
you is a response that many people take
to the problem on the relationship
between this realm of hopes dreams lost
and the reality that does not conformed
to it and what happens when it's not
integrated so now let's talk about some
of the more even philosophical meats
having to do with reason passion desire
and there is this long essentially
diatribe carried out a dialogue against
a enlightenment scientific way of seeing
things and so let's let's start with the
starting problem why is the good and the
beautiful
the classic you know values not only of
the Enlightenment philosophy literature
civilization in general why do they set
us off the rails so the more conscious
that wasn't the good and beautiful the
deeper I sink into the model the more
likely
fired that was my normal state something
no I tore out myself gave myself a wait
till the bitterness turn into some
shameful occurs the swedishness and
finally into a great unquestionable
pleasure why is it that some people can
actually take flutter like you says in
the blinding realization of my
degradation how can how can somebody
find the ugly and the bad to be good and
beautiful to be pleasant what's the
explanation for this pleasure he says
he's going to discussion of revenge and
he talks about the man of reaction and
the intellectuals response to situations
why do we want women what we feel like
somebody has offended somebody did
something to us they said something they
hurt us in some way they overlooked us
the man that actually gets offended and
that desires revenge tries to take
revenge as they can and they see all of
that as justice right if they didn't see
it as just their if somebody comes along
and tells them that's not the right
thing to do I may actually believe it
then they say okay I guess I won't do it
though that's what he talks about is
like a stone wall you know if the man in
action if you put a stone wall in front
of these stops right there now he's sort
of contempt sort of like a horse or a
cow when you put up a fence they don't
usually jump over that's once they get
used to it they're like offense they're
over there is a defense you know
the intellectual wants to get revenge as
well and then you defendant even easier
because they
much easier time taking the fence right
there if we read into things so much
easier they'll even get offended that
the other person not realizing that they
offended the intellectual so how could
you not know that that would be
offensive to me then again you know you
can think of a lot of people like that
you know who are just just rancorous and
surprised that you didn't know that this
was offensive to them you know it seems
like it changes every five years or so
now you should not talk about this
subject or don't use this word don't get
so angry with you but they get angry
with you and they will it'll raise their
voice and use words you know call you
hateful and you know maybe shake their
fist or something like that will they
actually punch you out
no because they're not they're not men
of action or women of action right real
men and women of action don't punch you
out they don't like what you're saying
they'll pop you in the face you know and
then quite often you know things can you
worked out the intellectual is sore
that's it faster there and they take in
the wreck revenge they wait until they
can do it and they find little ways to
be you know snide and sneaky and snarky
and all that and here's what's really
interesting yeah that's that's a classic
conference between open revenge and
passive-aggressive right like I said
before the man of action for dos
yesterday here thinks that what he's
doing is just me you might be wrong
about that but he feels that it's just
the intellectual feels that it's not
just that in some ways they're just as
bad
the person defending them and they find
themselves doing something bad in the
process to get revenge and that makes me
feel given the force you know this goes
all the way back to Plato and you know
the consciousness of badness if a bad
person he actually realizes the badness
of their reactions they're being
punished already in that and they can't
escape that so nevertheless they keep on
with all link it says to when it comes
to like you know laws of nature or you
know stolen walls or two plus two equals
four the man in action stops short
before that okay there's the
intellectual can't knock the wall down
can't refute it but like he says won't
accept it that's a key idea here the
intellectual part of the reflective
process is not to actually leap beyond
in a heroic way but to say I'm not gonna
accept it I don't like it I don't put up
I don't have to agree so let's look at
this issue that I'm being rational
recognizing as he says you do real and
the Enlightenment
the focuses on being rational and
recognizing one's real choices he says
there's a set of you know arguments
basically following from each other but
any he lays out sort of a caricature who
was it that first said that man knows
nasty things only because he doesn't
know where his real interest lie that if
he were enlightened about this true
interest he would immediately stop
acting like a pig and become kind to
normal
being enlightenment the being
enlightened the argument goes on seeing
where his real advantage why he would
realize it was an acting virtuously and
since it's well established a man who
Manik deliberately against his own
interest if follows he would have no
choice but to become good and that's
that's pretty much it for the
Enlightenment
right if you just knew what your real
interests were and what it meant to be
you know good flourishing human being
you'd knock off all your BS and the
meeting they start working on yourself
and trying to be good and rational and
maybe even pure and make the rest of the
world like that too so don't ask
earrings have three problems with that
problem one he says
problem two is
you defined what actually is any
interest problem so these are three big
problems I mean if the Enlightenment
viewpoint could actually take into
account all these things and somehow
select the bed and chew them up and make
sense of them and address them fully
then they would be okay but it actually
can't and then so it's interesting
there's kind of subduction I'm the part
of reason about how great reason is so
Dostoevsky says this
all these lovely systems all these
theories that explain to man what is to
his true advantage so that to achieve it
he before with become good at normal all
these are in my opinion nothing with
sterile exercises and logic yes that's
all there is to it men love the abstract
reasoning and need systemization so much
they think they're nothing of distorting
the truth closing their eyes of yours to
contrary evidence to preserve their
logical constructions here's an example
you know as a man I mean itit becomes
more enlightenment they should become
less bloodthirsty more civilized now
this is before World War one or a lot of
European intellectual design said oh my
gosh there was something wrong with that
idea
Dostoevsky says you only have to look
around you to see blood being spilled is
the most playful way just as if it were
champagne look at the United States that
into soluble Union plunged into civil
war multiplied our history that still
what does it then it's mellowed by
civilization all that does I'd say is to
development man a capacity to fuel a
greater variety of sensation nothing
nothing else and through this
development man will learn how to enjoy
bloodshed that leads us to the third
problem right what if the interest would
occur genuine interests are beyond
things he also talks about reason as
well he says I reason is a good thing no
argument about that but reason is only a
reason and it only
and rational requirements desired around
the other hand as the manifestation of
life itself of all of life that it
encompasses everything from reason down
to scratching myself although whenever
guided by our desires life may turn into
a messy affair it's still life and not
as a series of extractions of square
roots I for instance instinctively want
to live to exercise all the aspects of
life in me and not only reason which
amounts to maybe only one twentieth of
the whole he also says what does the
reason no it only knows what it is is
that everything yep so how do we
actually know we're doing things
exclusively out of self-interest is that
just sort of a logical construction
involved and theories that want to
rationalize everything they just roll
everything into self-interest and sort
of assume that it's there somewhere
desire if it wants to can agree with
reason especially if one uses experiment
never going too far that desire is quite
useful even creature movie but really in
reality desire usually stubbornly
disagrees with reason and let me tell
you that this is also useful and
praiseworthy pß what about the scale how
do we actually measure the how do you
define he says interest what interest
can you define exactly what is in the
interest of the human being and suppose
the interest of a man is not only
consistent with but even to man
something
is there any accurate scale of human
advantages
aren't there any advantages that are
emitted that cannot possibly be included
in such a scale and as as far as I can
understand this is another point he's
making you based your formulas you based
your scale of advantages on statistical
averages of the scientific formulas
thought up by economists and since your
scale consists of such advantages as
happiness prosperity freedom security
and all that a manner just deliberately
disregarded that still be granted by you
as an obscurantism utterly insane what's
really remarkable is that all your
statisticians stages of humanitarians
when listing human advantages insist on
leaving out one of them they never even
allow for a dozen validating all their
calculations what manage is that well
that's when we get to this what was the
interest of the human being actually
were to have their own way even if it's
damaging even if it's destructive he
sees he says perhaps there's something
that every man values of the highest
individual advantage where there may
exist a human advantage that is the most
advantageous which is also more
important than the others and for the
sake of which a man indeed people go
against reason on our security and
prosperity insured against all the
beautiful and useful things
what is it says that's a question of
words before I name this advantage let
me go on what is it man will give up
earring of his own free will stop
imposing his will
to his interests well what is in his
interest later on he says one's own free
under strange choice one's own with yet
the wildest ones own fancy sometimes
worked up to a frenzy then is the most
advantageous advantage that cannot be
fitted into any table or scale and that
causes every system and every theory to
crumble it's a dump
so all of this is on the fly when
wanting to do things your own way
wanting to be what you want to be even
if it doesn't make sense even if it
doesn't ultimately bring security
prosperity honor happiness even if it
goes against these things one can say no
to what's being offered to you this is
the Crystal Palace be enlightened that's
what we're going to ask you the evil off
of this this this image that he has on
the Crystal Palace created by the men of
science where everything is light and
truth and harmony and everything fits
together he says
and if you want to cure human beings of
all of their problems you want to lead
us through engineering and science to
this this crystal palace in which
everything will fit and I'm going to
stick my tongue out man and I want to be
able to stick my tongue out and I don't
want a place which will turn me into an
automaton a time where I wouldn't even
think of staying my time because it says
what I'm for is win and I want the right
to use it whenever I want to I know for
example that suffering is inadmissible
at light stage plays in the utopian
Crystal Palace it would be inconceivable
her suffering means doubt and denial and
what kind of Crystal Palace would that
be a big letdown so when I remember the
less uncertain that man will never give
up true suffering that is chaos and
destruction I know that he likes it and
won't exchange it for any advantage so
again very typical existentialist piece
in many respects we've got ourselves to
the point where we see that at least for
the underground man and the portrait of
human beings is being presented it's not
saying the enlightenment isn't there
it's not saying these things hard
advantageous it's saying this can't be
brought within the scope of your system
and this is important this is part of
the essence of humanity but how do you
nail down a minute
could you come up with a catalogue of
them it wouldn't be women so that's
where we belong and yet another
important existential piece of
literature by Fyodor Dostoevsky